payment forms are another type of form
that you'll likely use in your product
you want to keep these simple and easy
to use so that way the user can focus on
purchasing the product you'll also want
to provide different payment options
this form looks a little long but at
least there are different options for
payment Gumroad is a startup that does
this really well Gumroad connect sellers
of digital products to buyers you could
sell or buy a variety of things on
Gumroad let's say I wanted to buy a
music management book I can click on I
want this and I get redirected to the
simplest payment form however don't
mistake simplicity for lack of design
the devil is in the details with this
form and there are so many great details
the price for the item is clearly
displayed here input placeholders
describe what each field should contain
and even on the credit card we can see
that the format hints at the spacing
between groups of four numbers I also
need to enter a two-digit month a
two-digit year and a CB code when I
start typing in my payment information
the form selects the credit card that
I'm using don't worry this isn't my
credit card many credit card companies
have reserved prefixes eventually I'll
need to enter a CV code as well and this
form tells me where to find it for visa
it's on the back of the credit card for
other credit cards such as American
Express we can see that the CV code is
on the front of the credit card now the
one thing missing from this form is some
indication of trust there's a lock down
here but I don't really know what this
means another website called UX Pen
reminds users about security and
encryption on their payment form some
other sites use logos like these to
remind users about secure payment
methods these types of details increase
conversions and make for great user
experiences they can make your users
love not only your product but also how
they buy it